okay so I just got done watching the
drill and I okay so this is the Episode
II they got this giant drill outside of
Ba Sing se they're trying to get their
way in they're trying to breach this
giant wall which they do a very good job
showing the size of this thing and how
long it takes to get up and down the
wall they really show the size of it
very well and they have to just stop
this thing from bringing down the wall
and the three girls are in there Azula
and the other two the Fire Nation has
this army coming in all the earthbenders
go to try to stop it and I can't stop it
is up to the avatar and his friends to
go in and try to break it from the
inside out tried to destroy the inside
to destroy the outside and it just built
and built and built and this simple plan
somebody gets a little bit more
complicated and they just need to push
it but then the girls find out where
they are they try to attack him and then
they split up and they go in two
different directions and then you have
the avatar he heads out he just needs to
deliver the finishing blow but then
it'll come down starts using her
lightning but then the earthbenders
start throwing the rocks down they're
using those rocks to throw at each other
and then the Aang gets knocked out and
Azula guns and she's gonna try and
deliver the finishing blow but then he
gets this rock hand out of the wall and
uses that to fight her off and then he
climbs up the wall who turns around that
music is building those Alessi's he's
gonna down she shoots the lightning he
go through the winding deliver the
finishing blow and kaboom the drill is
destroyed
holy fuck I'm watching this I'm like oh
my god man that was just so fucking huge
and epic and when it was all said and
done they're like you know one of them
says we lost and they're looking over
the drill is stopped and bossing say
seems to be safe and the three or four
now they're just gonna go into the city
look for Appa and after all that
awesomeness I said if you get rid of
this episode would we have missed
anything important
hey wait sounds horrible because this
was so big it's so epic and so huge and
the whole episode was just dedicated to
taking this thing down and the tentacles
are taken down it was unbelievable the
detail that they spent on this uh and
they had the Sun setting while the
climax was happening and it makes for
wonderful colors and these wonderful
angles and like I said the music some of
the best in the series man just kept
building and when it was all said and
done I was just wondering like if they
got to Ba Sing se
and just went inside start looking for
Appa what was gained from this episode
really in terms of the story and I blame
my brother for this because he's always
like it was that to do the story how
does it further the story or the
characters or anything and I mean he
just asked that with everything and
probably rightfully so but but now it's
just ruined to be because I can see
something as awesome as this and
question why um it's all I'm really torn
on it I guess maybe if they write it
back in or they're they work it all
together maybe up but I don't see how I
could it doesn't seem like anyone
learned anything or evolved to anything
uh I mean again he gets a nice technique
and philosophy like about you know the
flow of the Chi and pressure points and
stuff like that like that stuff so cool
it's a it's not just a cool episode it's
a fucking awesome episode but in the
grand scheme of things I'm wondering if
it adds up to anything uh maybe we'll
maybe somewhere it'll tie back in but as
of now I'm just like that was the most
awesome filler
I know people hey do I use that word but
right now it seems like filler so uh I
don't know I hope it ties into something
because it was such an incredible
episode but hey you know what you know
it doesn't it was still incredible it
was still really great and the it was
like one long climax and it was a really
good climax over the live action and a
lot of great techniques in it again
wonderful angles I
love that they have the Sun setting as
this is going on I thought that created
some really nice some nice purples and
nice yellows and oranges so that it's
really really good colors in it um and
again I'll really credit the music on
this one too the way it just built and
built and built and you know it starts
off from a simple idea which I like that
sock is now they seem to be very aware
of serve their own tropes and cliches
and seem to they have fun with it in
just the right way for example there's a
scene where aang says oh whoa is it just
now all I need is in a rock falls right
next to me says huh for once it actually
is what I need and you really feel that
it's a genuine laugh because you go yeah
that really feels like something he
would say at that point cuz everything
always seems to be against him so when
something actually does coincidentally
fall in place for them that maybe even
too conveniently I would say this time
but when something like that happens you
can actually say yeah you know fair
enough
you know you do need a little you know a
little joke there a little
yes something goes right my way um so
yeah a wonderful action wonderful
wonderful detail on taking this thing
down again I love the creativity of when
they need one of the engineers to come
into the place so they destroy something
there and there's a bunch of steam and
Katara uses that to freeze the guy the
steam to turn it into ice cold and
freezing I love little touches like that
even though there's probably about a
dozen scenes where you could go way to
make couldn't your vendors do this or
the waterbenders do that or they aren't
there other ways around those but um but
I still love their really really putting
a lot effort into what they can do with
this stuff uh ever get I want to nitpick
like what she's holding all that rock
water splurge whatever that is I mean
she's all just holding her hand up like
this like no other effort I'm like wait
man and that seems like a pretty big
deal to just be like and she can even
make fun of her brother or throw other
water on him while she's keeping them
I'm like wait a minute there's there's
more to this than that the show has
demonstrated um
same thing with the earthbenders I
really felt like they're trying to stop
this big drill thing and I'm like
there's other ways to do this come on if
she can just go like this and hold all
that water rock stuff in there I mean
the earth benders can just like make one
big rock take that drill it just go
Shoom so that's really nitpicking though
um this episode like I said had so much
good action the only other thing okay
I'll talk about that there's a the other
story is with Zuko and the uncle and jet
and mantas ain't go where I thought it
was gonna go this well first of all I
thought they're really indicating I
should probably hear from the last
episode I thought they were indicating
that Jett knew who he was because he
says he pretty much says I know who you
are or I know the story behind that scar
or are you relying about it or
protecting our identity or something I
mean what wouldn't you get that he knows
who he is a maybe not but oh man I
thought maybe they're gonna do like a
friendship or something and they's gonna
betray and I'm even says I could use a
friend you know relying on others is
good and then what did they do he's like
come join a brother it now and walks off
and then he's like way to make he's a
firebender let's go get him it's like oh
man when you gonna done with this it
they could have like got really close
like brothers or something and then
maybe gen would have found out later or
again maybe Jett knew the whole time
he's trying to manipulate him and maybe
that whole trust thing that he already
had problems with is just made worse oh
you good what you could have done with
this instead he just made Jett them you
just emphasize what a boring character
he is I'm looking for change that's why
I'm going to Ba Sing se firebender oh
let's go get him it's like that
nothing's changed
ah so uh for now again I mean that's
that's the words or the words you're
probably noticing I'm using a lot is for
now or let's see or
you know and that's always the trick
with the with the show is that you don't
know what they're gonna do maybe they'll
do something really good that I never
thought of but as of now man I hope you
got something good plan with that
because there are some real good
possibilities with that and instead it
looks like they're going serve a
different silly route um I don't know
well we'll see where that goes but like
I said it could be totally wrong could
be totally wrong always open to that
that's difficulty for viewing a show
instead of a movie is that when a movies
done it's done there could be a little
to be continued but for the most part
it's done with a show it's like like you
know where the hell it's gonna go you
don't know they're gonna actually like
surprise you with something or lead you
down different avenues so whenever I say
huge stupid jerks he should have known
to do this maybe they are doing that it
just make you think they're gonna do
something else so I don't know uh I
don't like where it's going now but
hopefully they'll turn it into something
else
um or half turnt it I mean I chose done
it's been years out but but you enjoy me
talking about it like it's it's
something new so um so yeah it's it is a
good episode I'm not gonna say it's not
it was very enjoyable and I mean a
heart-pounding great action uh
as action scenes go I mean this is just
like one long big action scene it's done
really really well uh I would like it to
tie more into the story if it doesn't
you know what the action so good I'll
take it it's still really really
enjoyable so um that's it I'll see it
the next one